I'm not Shane people are ashamed of me
existing was that too far that's a
little too real um anyway guys hey Brian
right apparently and I'm Ariana ba Suri
Arianna Bhaskar and I are gonna check
out the trailer for a Netflix film that
Adam Sandler is the star of I believe
and Adam Sandler is Ariana's favorite
comedian he's Jewish
she's Jewish and he's the only Jewish
community only Jewish might be my
favorite I did physically run into him
in Boston once how was that I was I was
like oh my god I'm sorry
and then later I think yeah go
what's this now orphan Indian I'm fixin
to rob the bank here in town his name is
white knife
where a man can't ride five miles in
this territory without running into
alcohol it's a lot not the lowman in the
West I wouldn't know which way then
they're ridiculous sakes rode off to the
Frank stockburn is your father raise
your hand
who are you people we are the starter
brother how would you like to
participate you guys ready to go save
dad works better if you have nice Jewish
Domini I'm really hungry
girl mom low for a cafe well I'm affable
there is he doing a southern accent
[ __ ] people yeah they've all worked
with they've all practically worked with
uh I'm selling before mm-hmm make sense
I don't know if I'm really gonna care to
check that out it reminds me the one
that um Seth MacFarlane
yeah million ways to die in the West
Rachel is not the greatest comedy I
personally I know really no one really
likes Adam Sandler these days I like
Adam Sandler still he seems like he
doesn't really give a [ __ ] at all in his
performance maybe that's the character
but it also seems like it's Adam Sandler
no way to succeed yeah it's a nice job
trying it is a way to succeed but
there's also a limit where you just
don't care about anyone well it's
interesting with Taylor Lautner maybe
he'll bring in some of the tweens oh
yeah Taylor Lautner I like that they're
making Taylor Lautner a character he's
not pretty boy too he's naturally sexy
he can't change that
I mean look at him he's your type
Taylor Lautner yeah too pretty for you
fine he's my time I ain't got nobody
saying he has to be your time [ __ ] I
mean yeah besides the fact that it's
jam-packed with stars and sounds line up
he can do that with his films already I
feel like at first it looked like this
could be a different Adam Sandler movie
because it looked kind of cool at first
but then once it went into this is
comedy it felt like they can all the
cool stuff it makes me miss like 50
first dates kind of what I wanted from
this was like r-rated raunchy comedy
from Adam Sandler cuz I'm like we don't
get enough of those and Adam Sandler is
best when he's not restricted yeah yeah
I gotta admit like the quality of the
content does not look as as good as like
other Netflix originals and I feel like
you're gonna get such me why they're
Siri what series well if you're gonna go
for a movie I feel like they should be
on par with this series right
I was thinking about house of cards how
that's like it feels very big budget
yeah I feel cinematic there
feels very cinematic right something
about this just seemed like Adam Sandler
being aware that this is only going to
be on Netflix new self-aware where you
didn't care at all about your fans you
just can't know I'm just judging this
off the trailer for all I know this
could be the best thing Adam Sandler has
ever done I feel like so nerds are gonna
watch this high and they're gonna
appreciate it I will totally watch this
high I will watch this on Blue Dream
Northern Lights there is pineapple it
was actually a long Burgundy out there I
know trophy wife
yeah there's also lambsbread and
electric lemonade that's a good one
Electric the green crack super green
crack extreme green crack not interested
in crack weed well it's not really
Justin I'm really Angie tangi you know
what I'm excited for this movie yeah now
I'm really excited for this movie
pre-game did well this holiday season
celebrate your Hanukkah by watching
ridiculous six maybe I'll do a full
reaction to it the whole movie
apparently got a deal in the works I
might allow me to do that Oh long time
I'm even like who the [ __ ] Simone anyway
dudes and dudettes and genitals if you
guys are new to chick I'm talking Ariana
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe today by clicking this
button become a reject we've listed the
men and you can follow Ariana on her
Channel she's a comedian she's a funny
one she's a funny one eh huh tell us a
joke
Ariana make a slap monkey ah sorry about
that Ariana yeah
no fine I don't know what you've seen
everything fine I'll do my this is a
short one I wear a lot of metal at the
airport because I like attention thank
you
flappers did Instagram that with my
picture and my quote promotion complete